welcome back to pittsburgh uncensored
last week i asked the award-winning
singer macy gray what a woman was she
gave me a simple honest answer which
sadly triggered an avalanche of online
abuse she branded an ignorant bigot and
a transphobe and eventually went on the
nbc today's show in america to backtrack
another church of england struggling
with that question too announcing it has
no official definition of a woman that
additional care is needed when trying to
answer it all very weird well lord
robert winston
the world leading scientist in the field
of fertility and reproduction joins me
now lord wisdom first of all thank you
for coming into the street we've had
some logistical issues and we really
appreciate you making the effort to
still do the interview so thank you uh
can you answer for me this very simple
question what is a woman
of course i can't answer the question
anyway a woman is a female and the
female is defined by the genes she has
essentially she has two x chromosomes as
she's human normally and that would be
that would be the
definitive it's probably easier to
define a male a male has specific
masculine genes which make us different
from women and
the female position is the default human
position that that is to say if there's
no male genes there you're born as a
woman
but i mean dictionaries just simply say
a woman is an adult female and a man is
an adult male
why is the world finding it all so
complicated now
it is really quite extraordinary
basically we are a cluster standing here
i'm a clump of about eight trillion
cells at least each of which of those
cells has got my maleness in it i'm
defined genetically every single cell
has got those male genes and that would
apply to a woman who doesn't have those
genes so that what makes a difference
and we cannot escape the fact that we
are
genetically determined in this way of
course they define in terms of shape for
example where they have breasts and all
the rest of it but essentially that's
what it amounts to
so when we have what obviously it's a
complicated debate about uh trans people
for example and as i've regularly said i
i completely support trans people's
rights to fairness and equality
i just have an issue where
you see women's rights get eroded in the
stampede for trans rights and i just
don't think you can create a new
unfairness and equality for example in
in sport and so on
do you think that what we're doing as a
society is conflating
sex and gender which is the point that
jk rowling and others have made strongly
yes piers of course you're absolutely
right and there's no question that we
can change our gender we can do it by
mutilating ourselves we can remove bits
of our body and therefore change our
shape and so on but you can't change
your sex because that is embedded
actually in those genes in every cell in
the body that's the difference and that
really becomes a problem because of
course occasionally you end up with
let's say somebody who is born a male
but then wants to be become a female so
you can have that mutating operation for
example but then the question is should
they be allowed to compete in sport
that's a major problem because of course
they still will have certain male
characteristics which will likely give
them an edge over other other other
women and so that is where the problem
really i think lies and of course also
the issue of just social behavior in
different situations using toilets using
bathrooms a whole range of issues like
this which understandably worry women
well i've got a woman here esther draku
and you're listening to lord winston
he's honestly one of the most eminent
people in this field in the world are
you satisfied with that definition i'm
more than satisfied it physically pains
me that we have to even define what a
woman is because cavemen knew this but
apparently the most educated people in
human history don't know it so you know
thank god he's here to save the day
lord i want to talk to you also about
elon musk who's a fascinating character
but he believes we have a huge
population problem in the world that
actually we need more people not fewer
people do you agree with him
well you know i think elon musk is a
wonderful individual in what he does but
actually he's not a biologist and
let's just be very clear i don't think
it matters very much because the world's
population will not depend on elon musk
it will not depend on politicians it
will depend on the environment and of
course under the right circumstances the
population will certainly expand
if there is as likely to be starvation
in other parts of the world it will
decrease
what i think we are seeing though is
that rich countries the population is
certainly diminishing but in poorer
countries it isn't because they don't
have the ability to control their births
or they don't have they need more people
to support them in old age for example
and that i think is a fundamental issue
but the world could support a lot more
people if in fact we had better
provision for a whole range of things
like food supplies and so on
are you happy that the political
population of this country
is about to have one less member in
boris johnson
well i don't understand the man frankly
i mean i think he's been unbelievable
it's really difficult to understand why
he insists he wasn't going to resign for
example then of course finally he had to
it's very ignominious and i don't think
it's a great representation of our
politics it is so sad because there are
so many really good politicians around
but we need people actually who have
that sense of actually understanding
what the limits are of what seems to be
power i think for some reason he almost
became a sort of he wanted in his mind a
kind of dictator
this this is an extraordinary thing for
somebody who's a con a conservative who
actually should be conserving the
political arena
yeah i completely agree uh of any of the
runners and riders left in the
leadership race do any of them excite
you can you see yourself being happy
with any of them as prime minister
well you know to tell you the truth i
think this whole uh election process
which the conservative party is going
through is a pretty rubbish contest i
mean how you can choose just two people
out of a pool of 20 or 30 and then put
them in front of another electorate
which also is hand-picked by their
membership of that party it doesn't
actually make complete sense it isn't i
think the way a democracy should work
perhaps this can't get sorted out until
finally we have a proper general
election and then we might have some i
think we need to but i think the real
i'm sorry
i could talk to you again a lot longer
and i would love to soon if you don't
mind about to leave you there thank you
very much for your time esther thank you
whatever you're up to keep it
unsensitive good night
you